all right today's video on cringe report
oh tick tock
[Music]
i'm getting ready for my big sister's
wedding she didn't want me to
be one of her bridesmaids she walks in
and asks what's wrong
[Music]
this is really confusing we're not doing
15 minutes
why not but we're not how do you know
this is just not my thing
i've already had enough and i have an
explanation for all this
really i haven't had enough so i need
you to bear with me a little bit oh
okay go ahead this is giving me anxiety
oh my god i'm legit like i have hives
all over my body
you try to make a deal with the son of
the devil thug
he warns you what his father wants
[Music]
oh i know what this is oh brother i'm
legit having a
i think i'm having pennies i know what
this is oh i know exactly what is
happening to my body [ __ ]
what's called you're rejecting this is a
cringe
you know when you eat too much you got
itis oh man i haven't had this since i
was like a teenager
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Laughter]
coat
[Music]
now she's average
which is not better but she's average
you had enough
i didn't cringe i was like uh
i felt really uncomfortable you know
what this is let me tell you what this
is all right
back in 2009 2008 7 whatever it was a
wonderful show on tv
called so you think you can dance
all right on that show there was a judge
her name was me and michael
i believe the style of dancing she was
doing was
lyrical contemporary it's basically very
like
dramatic and you add and stuff like that
and i've seen in the dance scene
a lot of these classes popping up
people that were qualified to do it
people that were not very qualified to
do it
even the hip hop changed to what that
was they were trying to tell stories
with the face you know super dramatic
you know
it's too late to apologize you know all
that because people really want to act
oh my god i can dance
and act and that might feel people want
to do that they've always been doing
that
right the thing is dancing is not really
so much a thing no more
and you know with other platforms having
copyright issues you don't see so much
of dancing videos out there because you
know you get cut real quick
for using music that is not yours this
is like kind of their way of acting
now having little stories a lot of
people
want to be actors and that's kind of
their way in their fantasies to be
actors or live something else
you know what i mean i've seen people
when i was in an elementary school or
high school they were
writing little screenplays with their
with their friends and stuff like that
that's what that's just what that is
people want to act they want to be
actors they want to do that and now
right now since everybody got a bunch of
time on their hands
well they do this stuff is it good is it
bad
it is what it is to me it's really is
what it is i'm not gonna be like oh my
god
i don't get it no i don't get it but i
get it
but i don't care about it that's pretty
much what it is people want to act so
much
that they do their own thing so maybe
something's going to come out of it
someone's going to become famous but
really just
living like a florida suit of fantasy on
that
it's like a comic-con why they want to
reenact their favorite
it's a bit that cornier but it's a bit
that people want to reenact certain
things because
they want to feel certain things they
want to you know embody certain
it's crazy but my mom used to shop she
used to take um
hangers coat hangers i used to take coat
hangers broke them into it in half
boom i got a gun and now i was like in
the forward so what's up
they're just using their imagination now
you just have the tools where they have
their phones and they could share that
there's a bunch of people back in my
days whether we do radio shows or tv
shows if their parents were rich they
had camcorders
so they would they would do tv shows in
the basement
where their friends or they would record
radio shows with their friends
and that's what they would do you know
that's just what it is why would you do
that it's just imagination and stuff
like that
so you create stories that's just what
it is
it's not my thing it's not everybody's
thing but i'm not gonna dog on people
that
you know that are doing that are doing
things like that if that's their nurse
it's corny some of it is borderline boy
and but borderline
i'm just trying to be nice that's the
least of my problems you know what i
mean i think i'm just glad
i didn't have the internet like this
when i was younger
this is just a trend people are jumping
on it because they want attention
they see what other kids do to get
attention so they take their phone and
they do it
and you know i was probably susceptible
this or some of this
i remember in high school this website
called high five came out
everybody signed up same thing with
myspace right everybody looks good
do you look good i mean sounds vaguely i
think i don't
i remember hot or not because you know
like all these different websites as i
was growing up
and thankfully like nothing was so
advanced that there's still a record
like i looked on my hi-five profile
last year doesn't exist anymore my
website's pretty much dead now
a lot of my old profiles don't exist
anymore so they've been pretty much
wiped clean
but what these kids make a lot of it is
going to stay permanently on the
internet forever
so all these little weird tick tocks and
all these little weird stuff that
they're posting about
wanting to you know epstein and
self-delete themselves and all these
weird stuff all going to be there
forever all that little
boy stuff there's always going to be a
record
so i just think whenever i see tick
tocks i'm just like
do your thing but i'm glad i didn't have
to live through that
oh yeah yeah it's intense what teenagers
have to go through because like this
stuff is super
depressing half of those are like about
getting
killed off and finding boyfriends and
fighting girlfriends i'm just like whoa
this is dramatic as hell is what you
guys really think about all the time
what we see that's what we see on tv man
what a lot of what we see in the series
people being jealous and stuff like that
it's
a lot of what you see i remember just
growing up on dragon ball team cartoons
so that was you
they see a lot of toxic anything is the
truth yeah well that guy didn't grow up
on that but when i was at the
high school i see a couple fighting
because she was not giving more
more attention people hitting each other
and stuff like that because to them
that was normal all right me
never yeah that's my whole point that's
what i'm saying
what these kids have to go through this
is so different than what i have to deal
with
and for them it's broadcasted everywhere
like when we would get bullied
only people who saw it knew about it and
maybe the friends of the friends
these kids it gets posted online for
everyone to see
i got one once i got home the police the
bullying stopped yeah i was home
i was like oh yeah oh all right even if
you want to bully me on my age it's like
you'd have to log on messenger
send me a message that only i could see
you know what i'm saying like
it wasn't like this stuff i don't know
like cyberbully when i was growing up
wasn't like a thing thing
no it was not so it's just what these
kids have to live i'm like ugh by the
ancients y'all definitely wasn't for me
man yeah no
definitely not for you you know i don't
even think yeah no definitely not
freezing i think that's what i think
away the most when i whenever i see tik
tok videos like
tik tok is like two percent funny [ __ ]
i think you're gonna say two percent
milk
who wants two percent to go for one
or four one or the other it's super sad
and the rest is really garbage that's to
me so i don't download it but um
here's the thing though it's like when
we were growing up you have to curate a
profile and pretend
that you had a personality these kids
have to video themselves and pretend
they have personality so it's even more
difficult
yeah you just put pictures on and now
yeah yeah yeah and you had the myspace
angles
they're literally called myspace angles
because of the time when they started
existing
when people figured out how to lie you
it's harder to lie on these videos so
i don't know it's just interesting to me
to watch it i'm just like this is why
it's more cringy
it's like my space but with extra steps
and higher difficulty [ __ ] what i'm
saying
where we were living on recruit they're
living on veteran difficulty
yeah and they have zero skill sets
they've never played the game
it's like if you compare it to your
parents yeah they just had to show up at
school and that was their personality
you know what i mean like everything is
always a step
every generation you got these things
and stuff like that that's why i'm not
really
yeah just the other day i saw this like
video of this couple like in high school
and the girl's trying to talk to the guy
and the guy doesn't want to talk to her
and he goes like look at me
look at me and she slaps him in the face
and everyone goes oh
and the video got millions of views
right and i just remember thinking
why am i seeing this there's literally
zero there's no reason for someone to be
filming this
and there's zero reason for me to see a
high school fight and it'd be viral
my nigga's just like yo you can't
believe he smacked that if i see
ian from oklahoma i'm gonna tell him hey
16 year old
you were a little like why am i saying
you know gavin from pasadena what
you know you live in canada why do we
know this stuff
i have so many embarrassing moments from
high school i am
elated that nobody got to see them
online
you know what's even worse being 16 and
knowing that you can google yourself
i google myself as an adult and i'm like
imagine being that age and being like
kid gets punked by four girls yo and you
got millions of views and you got
comments
like i look at my youtube comments and i
go ugh sometimes you know i go oh
that hurt sometimes imagine being 16 on
a video you didn't upload someone would
be like
yo from oklahoma is a little it's weird
so
walking down the shooting game
recognizing the sheet
for what i do right right it's weird
right
being recognized in the street for the
wrong reasons must be even worse
oh yo you're gonna do that doo-doo on
himself yeah i've seen you jabbing
that's just brilliant you don't even
know who the person is but we know
like everybody their parents once in
their life at least
but now i know i got a picture i got a
moment i got a place
i got a i could type that i could see
you
yourself numerous signs like
repeatedly oh yeah you didn't do that
that's crazy
so i i'm not gonna hate on tick tock i
just that's what i was thinking the
whole time i was watching this so
anyways we want to know what you guys
think
would you guys rather grow up in this
generation or do you like yours the
previous ones
what do you guys think about this whole
tick tock fast rather be this agent this
generation
for sure for sure for sure there's no
way i would drink like a fountain
of youth type of thing if i knew i would
have to
be raised with these monsters what's
your name gavin smith
well i see here that in 2015 you were
eating tide pods like yeah
i can't do this bro